i would say i just want to make things
but that's what everybody wants
I love seeing what I can make can I make
this can I make it happen is it possible
engineering runs in my family and if I'm
just idle for too long I look around at
the supplies around me and think what
can I make out of these I moved to San
Francisco about four months ago and that
was right after getting my master's
degree in mechanical engineering from
the University of Michigan within a
couple weeks of moving here I was
helping Ben Cohen of Ben and Jerry's to
make this roller coaster stamp mobile
project that was my first what I felt
like was a San Francisco experience with
the space helmet I didn't initially make
it would be intent of putting it on etsy
so I've worked out a price and I wasn't
even expecting any sales I just put it
on etsy for fun just to you know to
share it with more people because that's
what I initially made it for anyways
just to share this this thing that I
wanted to make it actually ended up
being really great I have already
shipped out to and I got pictures back
from one of the customers and she and
her husband absolutely love it most of
the stuff that i make i give to other
people but every once in a while I make
something for myself